thank you David so I'm item baloch from
the Berkeley Lab for those of you who
don't know where Berkeley Lab is if you
go up at her street right in between
here and the soda hall you'll eventually
eat the burlap it's a mud multi science
laboratory funded by the Department of
Energy so today I'm going to be talking
about parallel graph algorithms
paragraph computations and specifically
I'll focus on three aspects of in how to
get high performance how to get high
productivity and how to reduce
communication which is usual the
bottleneck in these computations of
course this a lot of people have
contributed pieces of this talk maybe I
won't even talk about those pieces but I
wanted to acknowledge all that is helped
and the people who has funded this work
so graphs are dear to us in for computer
scientists so graphs has been used as an
abstraction for a lot of things like
compiler optimization in scientific
computing to guide sparse drag solvers
or nowadays actually monitor solvers and
computer network algorithms but these
have been an auxiliary helper in the
sense that the data sets here when
you're running your compiler
optimization or you're running your
computer network is not that huge
because there's an inherent limit if the
it's how big your program is as the
graph is going to generate that you need
to optimize for the compiler right in in
nature the graphs themselves are a much
bigger for example the internet
interactions or social interactions they
create huge datasets particularly
interest to us at the Berkeley Lab are
scientific data sets where you're not
really limited by the size of your data
you're limited by your computation size
if you ask a cosmologist have how much
of a data set he has a much of a graph
it's like as big as I can solve because
he can he always wants to have more
resolution and that goes on for ecology
biology chemistry and so on and I would
like to make a distinction in the
beginning why I'm not using MapReduce
for
this kind of competitions it's very
personal very open to object so in my
world of view which of course these
colors are wonderful I'll need to look
at the screen to tell before I say the
red one because there's no red I kind of
loosely classify the graph competitions
into two classes one of them i call the
filtering base and these are the kind of
operations were your any Mary triangles
rectangles or you do some sort of
browsing scanning or summarizing the
data at the end a lot of sampling the
kind of problems that can be solved by
these algorithms and you've seen some
examples of this and this is really a
good fit for the MapReduce paradigm or
some database like angel sparkly bow
when you go to Marsh I would call
tightly coupled graph algorithms where
you need to traverse the edges and the
vertices of graph several times to get a
good car to solve your problem and
examples are betweenness centrality show
just pads network flow strongly
connected components those are really
hard to paralyze using MapReduce kind of
structures uke that's not to say that
you can't map it you can map every
competition to every abstraction it's
just that it is harder to do and is
probably not going to give you a lot of
performance so what is the challenges of
this life section is really love
arithmetic intensity unpredictable
access patterns because when you're
traversing a graph every time you take a
step you actually don't know where
you're going to go and you determine by
at runtime what your next step is going
to be and and difficult to parallel eyes
for that reason so let me start the
first part of my talk really high
performance and it's again another
personal with we think that the linear
algebraic primitives can be a good base
for a big class of graph algorithms and
they would work very well so what are
those just as a picture is not not all
of them the ones that I would like to
draw pictures of I'm talking about
computing the product of two sparse
matrices multiplying a sparse matrix
with a sparse vectors
and I mean I want to underline the
sparse here doing a lot of element wise
operations between matrices and
extracting sub graphs of course this is
a sub graph where it would be nice to
color-coded to know what it is but just
use your imagination it's some piece of
it but so except that these are not
running on your regular real numbers and
it's not the multiply and Plus that you
know of in the ring of real numbers so
you're allowed to arbitrarily overload
the algebraic structure that we call the
semi ring for the purposes of systems is
just like overloading the addition and
multiplication and defining an identity
element and the most famous one is
probably the tropical semi ring the mean
plus one that will let you soul singer
shortest bad problems and the end or one
that will give you connectivity problems
and so on I'll talk about a couple of
previously unexplored semi rings that
are not deep but haven't nobody has
actually looked at them down let you
stole a couple of different graph
algorithms and the word I use here the
combinatorial blast is the system that
we've developed over the years it's
blast here stands for basic linear
algebra subroutines and that's the
reason because it's a bunch of basic
linear algebra subroutines to do some
community really complicated so what
does it look like again not a
comprehensive list it really looks like
this are very simple sparse matrix
operations some of them really hard to
parallel eyes though really easy to
state multiplication sparse matrices
years multiplication sparse matrix with
a vector dancer sparse element-wise
reductions referencing assault the
getting a sub sub matrix assigning a psu
some of you
blink and ran
locations and probably to get people I
feel about how this would work in
practice I'm going to go over a simple
graph algorithm simple parallel graph
algorithm so before we move on this
slide the problem is finding a maximal
independent set that's very useful for a
lot of purposes but let's not get into
that detail a maximal independent set
first of all an independent set is a set
of vertices who are not neighbors of
each other so any two pairs within the
independent set do not share an edge
between them a maximal independent set
just like the maximum matching they've
been taught before is an independent set
that you can't grow by adding another
vertex it doesn't mean its maximum there
might be a bigger independent set but
it's just once i give you the
independent set you can't grow it by
adding another one so it's not an
np-complete problem the maximum would be
it's a very simple problem and a
sequential version actually runs in
linear time but it is sequential and the
parallel version a very simple one due
to michael lu b it's a randomized
algorithm works like this so everybody
in the graph every vertex chooses a
random number and then then everyone
looks its neighbors and determines the
minimum among its neighbors and if his
value is smaller than all these
neighbors then he declares himself as
part of the independent set so again
you'll have a problem with the coloring
these red colors now our independent set
and but after that what you can do is
you can remove all of its neighbors this
looks like a repetition of the maximum
matching algorithm kind of and because
they can't be in the independent set and
now you're left with the remaining ones
you just toss another coin boom you'll
find the complete set so the theorem is
that this will probably find finish
videon log and rounds and that's that's
usually good enough how do you implement
this in in a system that implements
graph algorithms in the language of
linear algebra and for this particular
slide I use what I k dt and knowledge
discovery tool
which is a Python front hand for the
community blast that I previously talked
I just don't want to put C++ code on the
slide so I chose to use this particular
version a Python version of that so the
input is the AJC's matrix of the graph
is sparse the sparse matrix I use this
transpose because some of the algorithms
will be easier to describe that way the
output is the maximal independent set
you initialize the candidates to all
numbers from 1 to n where n is the
number of vertices and you iterate over
this your first set everyone to random
numbers and here's the crux once you do
multiply these transporters of Tydeus
matrix with the vector of candidates but
using a special semi rink where all the
multiplications you just selecting the
second operand for all the additions
you're just choosing the minimum you'll
see that by using the same data access
pattern of matrix vector multiply you
will get an output vectors which are the
minimum among all the neighbors that's
actually pretty simple to think about
because think about the column on the
adjacency matrix column in the juiciest
matrix are your incoming edges or this
is this is actually symmetric don't
worry about it you're actually looking
at your adjacency and summing up all the
values in your adjacency using the
minimum operation that's about what you
want right you want the minimum that's
how you gather the minimal operation
very nice now are using this element
wise operation on the vectors you'll
figure out which one is that if you're
smaller than those minimum you get if
you're smallish you will eventually add
this new set to the maximal independent
set and the rest of the competition
again does prune out your neighbors but
the crux is here I have used the same
operation sparse matrix vector
multiplication twice using different
algebraic structures I don't need to
reimplement it I just declare that the
semi ring is different now and the
system will take care of doing another
competition and it's just optimized once
run several times and for another graph
algorithm you'll write a similar thing
you will never know how these things are
implemented
the best way it's the the job of the
expert in parallel computing and when I
remind something it's that the vectors
i'm using here in these operations are
sparse even though they start dense as
you keep pruning them out you'll see
that they'll get sparser so eventually
you won't be wasting competition later
so that will that is the crux that makes
these algorithms work efficient and no
worse than the canonical versions of
those what do I mean with the canonical
version is the one the best parallel
algorithm you find in your textbook for
that application that doesn't use the
linear algebra extraction and is a short
list of bills I could come up with and
this slide some of this is shamelessly
stolen from Jeremy Kepner the mighty
some of them is my additions breadth
first search between a sensuality I'll
pay shorts pads which I'm going to talk
towards the end of my talk some maximum
minimum spanning tree algorithms and
some maximal independent set algorithms
so in the first column you see the
canonical complexity of the algorithm
serial complexity the linear algebra
base complexity here in many cases it
matches the complexity of the canonical
version in the cases where it doesn't
match are precisely the ones that use
make a heavy use of the priority queues
and you'll see this for example prims
minimum spanning tree algorithm you need
a priority queue for that but the
problem the reason that they don't go
into the language of linear algebra very
well is because priority queues are
inherently sequential data structures so
that's probably there is a there is a
more fundamental reason that we can't
express this in the language of linear
algebra efficiently perhaps because they
can't be efficiently mapped a parallel
computing I don't know I don't want to
sound too controversial hopefully
somebody will match priority queues in a
scalable way not with locks or anything
Atomics like that so why do we do this
exercise you can tell me hey I knew this
these algorithms are already complicated
and you're trying to show me that you
have to map them to the linear algebra
and I think I have a headache why do I
do this so here's the here's a wheel the
textbook graph competition is
data-driven as I said unpredictable
communication patterns because you don't
know what your next step is a lot of
poor locality of reference you're
traversing over edges and vertices and
find great data accesses once you cast
them into the language of linear algebra
a linear algebra operation has the same
data access pattern every time you
execute you know at every iteration what
kind of data access a pattern is going
to be so you can overlap communication
and computation you can write code for
expecting that and similarly you can
look at the matrix and figure out block
structures that you will not be able to
see in the graph word that lets you
exploit some of the memory hierarchy
things and it helps you with parallel
computing as well and i'll let you show
an example for that so here's a example
about what do I mean so this is a graph
color coded for processes and this is a
its adjacency matrix so I am dividing
this graph to four processors using the
what we call the two dimensional data
decomposition as you might see this is
fairly obvious how you would do I the
sparse matrix for two dimensional data
two companies you just drove a Cartesian
grid over it right and it's not that
obvious how I actually got this thing if
I didn't see this vert and I was just
looking at the graph itself they again
another College of kept lost of course
this is great this is black but believe
me on that why do I do that the
two-dimensional decomposition allows me
to do two things one of them is it
actually asymptotically reduces the
computation and it reduces the number of
processors that are communicating you
don't need to do any all tall shuffling
you would need to do all the
communication is going to happen either
in the processor columns or in the
processor rose and that's why the
two-dimensional decomposition is the one
that's used for every single entry in
the top ten of graph 500 list
which is a benchmark that ranks
supercomputers based on how fast they
can do graph traversals using
breadth-first search so that's kind of
an example why this might be useful so
so far I've talked to you about linear
algebraic primitives and why we think
they're going to give us performance and
now I'm going to shift a little bit of
gears and try to show you how you can
get productivity and how you can sell
the system to scientists perhaps I'm not
going to actually go ahead and sell them
but it's a proof of concept way and the
cracks will be to use high-level
languages for the end user and only
specialized pieces of those code that
matter that and translate them into a
efficiency language that is you know C
C++ whatever you want so here's the
software stack that we think is very
scalable in the sense that you can let
me start with what is this we think of
three agents that in this world there
this the domain scientist is the
biologist the chemists or astronomy that
wants to use your system he doesn't know
about graphs but he knows he's a good a
graph problem he heard about the few
things like traversing a graph maybe he
knows about clustering and graphs and so
on but he doesn't definitely know
doesn't know parallel computing the
graph algorithm developers are the
people who understands graph but they
don't understand parallel computing and
lastly the parallel computing experts
actually are the ones that match your
given computation official in a parallel
computer so what you want to do is to
create a system ecosystem that enables
them to advance their pieces of these
things independently from each other and
we think this is actually a system
ecosystem that does that if you have a
high level language that gives
primitives for the graph algorithms to
use to write new graph algorithms and
expose them to the domain scientist this
actually takes care of both of them and
then
those but this will use the primitives
that are implemented in an efficient
efficiency language that's implemented
in C using MPI for message passing
between processors and the the parallel
computing experts can optimize these
primitives without knowing what they are
useful in the algorithm so that will
create an independent advancement on all
these fronts and so Combinator applause
blasts its ears and the K DT that I
showed you the code for maximal
independent sets sits about you can
think of this as Fortran and matlab if
it's going to help and this way graph
theory is becomes the middle ground
between computers and discreet discreet
structure analysis and what this allows
want to do is to achieve customizability
conceptual simplicity and performance
and what do I mean with those
performances performance I guess
customizability is a very subtle point
in the sense that when you are running a
graph algorithm almost neighbors you
want the textbook version that is
probably true right so when you're
traversing the graph you want to mark
the vertices and edges or you want to do
a little bit of computation on those you
just don't want to go ahead and scan the
whole graph and do nothing just figure
out the tree you you want to do some
auxiliary computation on that and we
don't know it beforehand it's the job of
the person who is using the system that
will customize these operations and run
them so you you would like the person to
be able to customize this and for these
purposes that is the semi ring I can
change the semi ring and do another
competition and in a second one it is
the filter which I'll describe in a
second so what I'm going to be showing
is this this is a historical slide
eventually you can get all three by
using just-in-time compilation here's
what I mean with the filter let's say a
practical example you have the email
network of your company and it has
emails of everyone management engineers
and so on every email is tagged with the
timestamp and that's what we mean with
attributed graph so every edge and
vertex has an attribute what kind of
person what time this happened
transaction happened perhaps the length
of the email whatever and then you would
like to rank all your engineers but only
your engineers using the emails subset
of that email set that happened in the
last month but you don't want to create
a copy of that data set because it
probably is huge you don't want to scan
all of it and create a copy or maybe
you'll change that filter so what you do
is you are two predicates it says the
vertex predicate returns true if the
position is an engineer at time to email
predicate returns true if it happened
within the last month and you add those
to your graph and you run your favorite
ranking algorithm with betweenness
centrality and it finds automatically
the most important engineer on the last
year without creating a copy of your
graph and because every time a vertex or
an edge is examined it's thrown away
during the execution the good thing
needs about this is the algorithm
developer who wrote this code doesn't
know about the filters because the
runtime filters the edges at the bottom
most levels and he doesn't need to know
what kind of filters are editing to the
graph so the conceptually all this
really looks like is you have a graph
but you're really pruning the graph you
get a sub graph every time you add a
filter but except that you're not making
copies if you were making copies for
every new edge filter addition you would
scan the whole data set and create
another copy create another copy and you
would need to keep those copies because
later you might pop them out and remove
those filters so you don't want to do
that that's exactly conceptually what we
call the filtering on the fly so what's
the problem with that imagine who who
rides to filter the person who writes
the filter is the leader is usually the
person who wants to run that analysis
tries to the person who's trying to find
the most influential engineer in the
last month Beijing emails so he's going
to write the filters in a high
productivity language he's probably
going to write the filter in Python
but all your system is running in in a
efficiency language C++ so every time
you need to filter an edge over text
you're doing an up call similarly for
when you're customizing your graph
algorithms using semi rings that I
talked earlier same up call the person
is going to write the power the Python
semi rink and you would need to do an up
call every time you're examining your
performance drop can be as big as 80 X
and then you lost all the performance
that you got by going parallel and so on
and in a picture it looks like this i'm
going to i'm going to come back to the
previous one so this is the knowledge
discovery tool box algorithm this is the
Combinator blast primitive so it calls
it but every time it needs to examine an
edge over text it needs to go make a
semi ring operation is making an up call
to python the how do you fix this is
actually fail it simple is a technology
called seats it's not our it's not my
contribution but it feels a big gap
between high performance and high
productivity it is a way of specializing
pieces of the complication using a
domain-specific language so happy that
it was collaborated with the sieges
people and wrote domain-specific
language just for filters and semi links
and it introspect translates the that
piece of the code so that it's linked to
the application and never makes a nap
call it looks like a simple solution but
it works drastically and you can get
both of the words for performance and
the productivity so the red line is if
we just don't do this you just run in
Python even if you use a
high-performance engine on the back end
just because doing the up course your
performance is over here and y axis is
time here if you your the yellow line is
the efficiency layer code in community
loss there's a huge gap in between by
translating both the filter and the semi
ring using seats you get the blue line
which is good enough for our purposes
and this is the maximal independent set
running on a big share
ray machine and this is breadth first
search running on a supercomputer with
576 course and you're actually almost
tracking the your golden standard your
efficiency layer code exactly and why
this is so close I can talk you about
that but I don't have the time right now
about it so what did we do so far we
talked about performance we talked about
productivity and we can get both of them
but I'm going to talk in the next five
minutes of the last five minutes about
communication a few people mentioned
communication costs in parallel
computing but it's only going to get
worse so how can we lower the
communication costs of these primitives
that's the performance part still but a
specialized version of that and the
cracks will be is to use some higher
level primitives that we know of and
implement communication of earning
versions of that I'm not going to give
you the model of competition probably
Jim demos will talk about this in a few
days instead I'm going to talk about why
it's more important for graphs than
probably other things like linear
algebra and that might sound
controversial the one of the main reason
is the graph competitions there is not a
whole lot of data we use so the
communication starts to dominate much
quicker then it happens in other pieces
of highly computationally intensive
codes in most of the graph algorithms
you're just touching one vertex or an
edge and you just throw it away so you
very badly dumb dominated by
communication and that's a picture where
we show the percentage of time spent
just shuffling the data around between
processors even if this is a very good
algorithm compared to the previous
algorithms quickly around 4000 course
you're spending eighty percent of your
time doing no useful work at all just
doing communication and this is
multiplying too sparse matrices that we
use for graph contraction or algebraic
multigrid restriction a couple of other
graph things but it doesn't matter the
example is just out of car
text it can be anyone so I'm just going
to give you an example about how to
avoid communication in one particular
graph algorithm because the the other
ones we're a little too long to tell
it's the all pair shortest path so the
input is a directed graph the output is
for every pair of reachable vertices the
shortest path length or actually the
path itself too if you care about it and
the classical algorithm is this the
floyd-warshall it's an outer loop other
product / 12 k and you can't change that
induction sequence because that's the
correctness but you can reorder the
computation in the middle well it turns
out that this is not the best algorithm
to get high performance in parallel
computers looks like it's a better
algorithm is due to clean which is a
recursive algorithm and all probably
that matters in this slide is that this
algorithm is rich in matrix
multiplication so you do a lot of matrix
multiplies except you do it in a semi
ring what that means is you're
overloading the plus operations with
minimum and you're overloading the
multiplications with additions and what
you will get by doing that because
you're matching their algorithm to a
very important and highly optimized
primitive matrix multiply and you can
come up with communication avoiding
versions of that matrix multiply you'll
get this performance so here is what i
have here this is running all pair
shortest paths on a small matrix small
graph of 4000 vertices and another graph
with 8,000 vertices the reason of this
small sizes is to show the strong
scaling because if you didn't do this
trick about communication avoiding
you'll get this a curve that looks like
this little hill the blue one but is you
strong skills you get extra memory you
write you if this data's fits on one
complete note when I fit it on 64
there's a lot of empty space in the
memory I can
a smart replication of the data in an
algorithmic levels and reduce my
communication requirements and that's
exactly what this communication avoiding
version does it uses extra memory to do
replication and increase performance and
you'll see by 440 application you get
over here by the application of the
amount of 16 you continue scaling even
for this small data set and similarly
much better scaling for the other one so
although David tells me this i have
minus two seconds mine tells me i have
one and a half seconds so that's about
it that will be awfully a pointer for
you to look at it later I any questions